hey guys what's going on welcome to the
fourth Python with TV basics tutorial
video in the last video what we did is
we showed how we can use the keavy
language for I suppose styling is the
best word I can think of for it and so
we saw how we made our basic hello world
application and all we're actually doing
in Python is returning label which is
referencing our key v file now I'm going
to call this simple key V to this simple
key v2 and now our actual key V file is
simple key B to zoom in here so now
we're going to go ahead and do is I'm
going to call this actually keep you
video for now and this works as long as
you only have one label now what happens
if you want our term like three labels
like our login application or all kinds
of things really and then also I was
talking about how you have parents and
children widgets and all this and how
you can customize based on that so
that's what we're gonna be talking about
here at least to start so we're gonna go
ahead and do is show how at least we can
have two buttons for example so of
course you could say button like this
like lighting and then add this text
that should work no problem but but then
what if you wanted to have only buttons
that were in relation to a specific
screen let's say or something like that
so that's what we're going to cover here
so what we're going to do is we're come
down here nationally we made one more
import and that's going to be widgets so
we're going to do is from TV UI X dot
widgets actually widget import widgets
now we're going to come down here and
we're going to say class and we're going
to say class widgets and widgets is
going to import for inherit rather from
widget which is right here so that's our
widgets class now we'll come down here
and our widgets class is actually just
going to pass now if we were putting our
TV kind of code within Python we would
put all that code in here
but I'm going to show you how we can do
it with the key B file instead for now
at least
so let's just delete this up to here and
now we're going to do is we're going to
say we're going to use these little
brackets and that's kind of to reference
your parents I suppose so
we'll say widgets for the widget parent
: 1 2 3 4 4 an indent and now we want to
do is we're going to say okay well
within the widgets class so this is kind
of like this is going to correspond with
this and it's going to know kvo is going
to know that we're doing that because
it's the name is simple key v2 so it's
simple key v2 is going to reference
simple q2 kv then it's going to say ok
well in this widgets a class what do we
want and then it returns it based on
here where we're returning label at the
moment but we can just copy the paste
and now we want it to return widgets and
it's going to reference this key v file
for information on widgets so within
widgets we're going to say there's a
button and that button is going to have
some parameters so those parameters are
going to be we're going to have size
we're going to have a position we're
gonna have some text will have a color
and then font size and our actual size
is the button width height so we're
going to make this button 100 wide so
it's pixels 100 pixels wide 75 pixels
tall now we have position this is a
little interesting in most GUI
applications on the computers zero zero
is corresponding to where well normally
it's the top left corner if you're
referencing let's say a try or a
rectangle it's a top left corner now or
if you're referencing a window it's
still the top left corner is zero zero
so if we were to position a button at
zero zero normally would be the top left
Cavey not the case zero zero is the
bottom left like a graph would be or
something like that
not sure why they've done it this way
everything else like HTML CSS zero zeros
top left every GUI I've ever used or GUI
development kit or something has always
been zero zero is top left I'm not sure
why they did it I'm sure they have a
good reason but they did so anyway
zero zero bottom left keep that in mind
too when you're positioning elements we
when you position an element you say I
want this element will say button to be
at zero zero what will be at zero zero
is the bottom left corner of that
element so this button is going to be at
zero zero so the bottom left corner now
what if our window was 100 pixels tall
and we wanted that button to be exactly
right at the top of our window well you
could position it at 100 pixels right or
actually I'm sorry it would be zero for
X and then why you would say let's say
100 pixels up but what would happen is
since we're referencing the bottom left
that button would be like the bottom of
that button would be right at 0 100 and
then the button would continue off the
screen up so you have to keep these
things in mind anyways for now 0 0 text
the text of this button we're gonna say
is Keeley the colors are an RGB a which
is red green blue alpha alpha as a
measure of opaqueness not transparency
some people say it's a measure of
transparency it's the opposite of that
color we'll say is a green so 0 1 0 and
then full the opaqueness I suppose so
you can't see it font size will or you
can see it or rather it's a solid font
size 40 ok now that's just one button we
can save that hopefully simple give you
two simple give you everything is good
let's run that and see how we do and
yeah you can see we have a button here
and interestingly enough this button
actually is somewhat interactive we can
click on the button and you see there is
some sort of not a super cool event but
there is an event when you click it
close this so we have that button now
let's say we wanted to add another
button how might we do that well we
would just do button :
and for simplicity let's just highlight
all that copy paste and the size we're
going to actually we're gonna call this
and then this one will be tutorial so
it'll be a TV tutorials because
tutorials is longer we need to make this
a little wider so 170 should be fine
position since this one was 100 pixels
wide we'll put this one at 100 starting
at 100 zero tutorials good will make it
a different color we'll say it's red
instead and font size can remain the
same let's save that let's run that and
now you can see we have these two
buttons TV tutorials now what I was
going to talk about positioning them at
the top but I think we'll actually save
that for a later video but like I said
before we can actually put some code
into here so for example let's say sighs
okay uh size let's say font size 40 uh
we could say font size equals I don't
know let's just say 80 divided by 2 just
to just a show
so font size is 80 over to run that and
you can see that still worked so we were
able to put you know some logic in there
and then later on you can reference you
take font sizes a certain aspect ratio
of like the whole window so to speak and
then also when you're placing buttons
you want to place a button right at the
top you can use some mathematics how
tall is our window how tall is our
button go to window height minus the
height of the button boom that's your
position of the lower left corner of the
button so to speak so anyways um more on
that later those are just the quick
basics of of this but as you can see
we've actually already got some
redundancy and font size now of course
we could have in Python over here you
could say well you could just set a
global variable and you'd be all find 80
and that's true but as things get a
little more complex you might find that
this is the superior method again it
just kind of depends on what your kind
of interests are what your comfort level
is what you're used to doing a lot of
people like like with Python a lot of
the complaints of some of my
videos have been that I like to code too
much into one one file instead of
separating everything off into its own
little file to me that's more
complicated more complex than necessary
to make a bunch of different little
files but to other people it makes a
whole lot of sense
it just kind of depends on you know kind
of what your style is and also the
complexity of your program sometimes
this is going to make far more sense to
use so anyways that's it for this
tutorial
if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time